Graphics in general are well suited to
handling opaque objects we can simulate
the lighting on the surface with a
simple equation and voila you have a lit
object but transparent volumes present
problems because of their very nature
there's no single surface point to
approximate in fact if you zoomed in on
this puffy little Cloud what you'd find
is lots and lots of tiny droplets of ice
and water light is bouncing around in
there and when taken as a whole the way
they reflect and transmit light inside
the cloud is vastly different than a
solid object it begins with an equation
called Beer's Law or the beer Lambert
law and it relates to these kind of
semi-transparent materials it basically
tells you how much light gets absorbed
given the distance into a medium the
light is traveling so if our scene here
is mountainous we can fog up the scene
by applying this exact equation x of
negative absorption times the distance
and what happens is as I crank that
absorption slider up the whole thing
fogs up nicely the fog that started out
in the distance starts to creep in a
little closer in a somewhat natural
looking way and there's no coincidence
that this basic calculation is one of
the classic fog calculations and
graphics
and in this case there's not much you
need to know beyond how far away the
point is in order to do the fog
calculation if I were to say bring an
object onto the screen instead and we
want it to be a somewhat cloud-like
material this is a bit different if you
look at the side view of the cube here's
your eye over here and you're looking in
this direction you need to figure out
how far through the object the Ray has
traveled in order to apply Beer's Law
which means figuring out where it enters
and then figuring out where it leaves
using those you can calculate the
distance in between and apply Beer's Law
using the equation above
given this distance then you can apply
Beer's Law using the equation above and
voila kinda gives you that impression of
a semi-transparent interior
so yet another problem is that we've
made an assumption here that the density
along this distance here was completely
constant
that it was the same the entire time
what if it isn't that means you can't
just blindly take this distance you have
to do a bit more work the next step then
is to take this vector and divide it
into a bunch of segments
then at each of these in sequence you
can sample your density multiply that by
the segment length and add it all up
then you can apply Beer's Law and now
you've kind of got Swirls and other
stuff happening inside this sort of
Cloudy interior so we're making some
very cool progress here it's very flat
though there's no depth to it if we
introduce a light to the scene well
nothing happens
we're remarking through our little
density field here but we don't really
have a way to react to lighting we
already know that the further into the
medium the light travels the more is
being absorbed
this is what we use Beer's Law for
but what we haven't figured out is how
much light actually gets to any given
point
so if you have a light source up here at
each of these points along this path
that you're sampling you need to figure
out how much light energy is there by
the time you get to that point
and similar to before since the medium
isn't uniformly dense what you need to
do is
starting from each point along here you
need to do a second set of samples
towards the light source once that code
is in place we can see that the lighting
is starting to take effect on our cloudy
object it's looking better already
jiggle the light around a bit and the
Cloudy interior seemingly gets lit
properly
although if you swing the light source
behind our cloudy object you don't get
that distinctive Silver Lining the real
clouds are famous for you're getting a
bit of light bleeding through but it's
not the same this is more smoke than
clouds why is that so we look at array
of light passing through the cloud in
reality it's going to get scattered by
the water droplets inside
until now we've actually been assuming
that lighting coming into the cloud is
getting distributed pretty evenly in all
directions
this is called isotropic scattering
but in real clouds as light enters the
cloud it doesn't scatter so evenly it
actually has a higher probability of
scattering forward and this is called
anisotropic scattering
so you use something called a phase
function to simulate that
and a common one is the hanyi Greenstein
model if we plug this directly into our
code and multiply the light energy at
any given point by this new phase
function
what we end up with is better
directional scattering as we move the
light around which is really cool
one of the interesting insights is the
original engineers at Guerrilla games
had was that clouds also have sort of
Darker edges and lighter creases
as light enters a cloud it begins to
scatter
points closer to the surface scattered
deeper into the cloud
points further inside the cloud have
actually received more scattered light
than points closer to the surface
the end result being that points and
cracks and crevices may have gathered
more light than points near the surface
the Gorilla Games Engineers called this
the powdered sugar effect because it
looks like powdered sugar
and their simple fix was to modify
Beer's Law a bit and drop off the energy
at the start so you've got x negative D
which is Beer's Law and you've got this
new powder equation 1 minus X of
negative D times two
and the combined equation might look
something like this which they called
Beer's powder approximation
and in the following years other papers
came out improving the look even further
the folks working on the frostbite
engine for EA released a bunch of
improvements to the original clouds
by mixing between a forward and backward
Henry Greenstein function they were able
to simulate a back scattering component
to clouds improving the look quite a bit
there was also a neat paper from some
engineers at Sony Pictures working on Oz
the Great and Powerful who noted that if
they took multiple samples of the
scattering lowering the extinction for
each and summing them up it would allow
more light through it basically looks
like this which you drop in as a
replacement for the Beer's Law
calculation when summing up the lighting
so we've got our little object and we
walk through most of the calculations
necessary all this left is actually
shaping this thing to be more cloud-like
in appearance
and that's where noise comes in
remember noise one of my favorite
YouTube channels the Bob's Burger guy
just covered noise and detail
the original paper specified they use
something called purlin warly noise
which is a combo of the two noises
although they don't exactly specify how
they're combined
so for warley you start with this basic
grid and at every cell in the grid you
place a point at the center
then using a noise or hash function you
offset it by some point moving it away
how far is up to you
then to calculate the noise for any
given pixel you figure out which cell
you're in and which cells are adjacent
you Loop through each of them figuring
out the distance between your sample
point and the neighboring cells offset
point and take the Min of all of those
you end up with something that looks
like this kinda organic looking by
inverting the color you get puffy
billowy shapes
the downside is that this doesn't tile
at least not at first but there's
actually a really simple fix
you modulo the cell offset so they
repeat
I was able to do this by adding a single
line to the warley calculation and voila
repetition in all directions
Berlin has a similar tiling problem you
can see that an fbm texture doesn't tile
well here
and unsurprisingly has a similar
solution a mod on positions in the hash
function
and scale that while generating each
Octave of the fbm and you've got some
nice tithing going on
easy peasy limits greasy this is where
things got pretty hand wavy in the
original paper
luckily the frostbite team goes into
more detail they used multiple octaves
of worldly noise to create what's
basically a version of war the fbm or
fractional Brownian motion then they use
that to remap purlin noise to get this
slightly cauliflower appearance
stuffing this into a 3D texture and then
using that to carve away pieces and you
start to see the cloud-like features
showing up
so now the really neat thing here is
that you can make pretty much any shape
you want if I use sdfs I can represent
cubes Donuts or even more complex
objects
the next issue is that right now I've
had to constrain the bounds of my cloudy
area pretty small in fact the bounds of
the area that I'm sampling just barely
cover what's being shown on screen
if I move the cloud you quickly see that
it runs into the edges of the bounds but
if I expound the bounds out too far
let's say 20x the size of the area It's
Quickly apparent that the approach falls
apart massively upping the number of
samples improves the look but tanks the
frame rate
assuming the clouds are implemented
properly at this point then it's mostly
an optimization game
this is where the authors talk about
using various techniques to speed things
up
they describe using a cheaper sampling
approach with larger steps and if and
when they hit a cloud surface they
backtrack and then start using high
quality sampling
I took this a bit further by using sine
distance fields to describe the cloud
surfaces and use sphere tracing check
out my video on Ray Marching for more
details
and then I switch to a high quality
sampler when I'm within a certain
threshold of a cloud
I also experimented with running this at
half resolution or lower and just
compositing the result I mean it's the
cloud so the details aren't super well
defined anyway or at least that's my
hope it looks alright
now there's way more you can do here
I know the frostbite paper describes
amortizing across multiple frames using
temporal scattering integration and
reprojection to speed things up but I
think I'm going to throw in the towel
here
this was a fun little project and I'm
certain that I got a whole bunch of
things wrong but it looks cool so I
can't complain
it's also an amazing illustration of the
sheer amount of hard work that goes into
just the background details in modern
games
code will be up on GitHub at some point
cheers